ciao benvenuti un nuovissimo video in
thailandia oltre a visitare ho comprato
anche delle cosine soprattutto delle
cosine che riguardano il mondo beauty e
soprattutto due maschere giusto due di
numero e oggi oltre ai mascheri farò
vedere anche altri prodotti beauty molto
particolari che ho trovato appunto in
thailandia prima di passare alle
maschere io partirei da questa crema per
il corpo è sì ragazzi è una crema corpo
al gusto chupa chups dal gusto all aroma
di fragola neutro ice che la vitamina c
e e acido ialuronico che ci credo molto
poco poco poco
l'estetista civica direbbe non vi
mettete la merda addosso ma noi vogliamo
provare la merda ma che il colore è
allora la texture e molto molto allora
sembra di spalmare beh come yogurt e
buono
quasi quasi da una leccata allora
sicuramente d'estate il metodo migliore
per farsi mangiare vivi dalle gare ma
magari anche gli chiedono allora profumo
è molto buono però è veramente
importante
no infatti non era di gomma l'asti care
ma mica si assorbe ma ai ragazzi non è
che ci marci griglia loro one e per me è
no c'è nel sesso non capisco l'utilità
aver mai che ci sono infine è a portata
di mano
secondo me la texture è molto buona
dc nel senso che come crema idratante
non è molto grassa il problema è la e
l'odore
dovete sapere che delle creme che
comprate non si deve essere mai
un ingrediente qua è il primo la
paraffina dopo l'acqua c'è la paraffina
liquida non va bene non va bene creava
corpo su prof.sse bocciata donna un
altro prodottino che mi ha incuriosito
molto arcova è un negozio coreano è un
gel detergente per il viso la schiuma
con il flaconcino con già la spugnetta
quindi praticamente funziona così
faccio solo su edoardo perché io sono
stata usata dai ok e ci laviamo il viso
ma che che avanguardia e molto fresca
l'assenza il john fresco di suo come
detergente però è comodissimo no
sappiamo con una cretina per vedere come
lascia la pelle
qual è la sensazione non so più niente
liscia se freschissima e molto fresca la
sensazione cioè pensavo ci fosse ancora
il prodotto veramente questo fresco di è
il trucco qui vado a stroncare per fatti
no lo proverò stasera molto buono buono
a possedere linci non si capisce una
mazza schiuma detergente con applicatore
con si chiama spugnette niente
autopulente super promossi ma io devo
provare ma mi sembra che non è liscio ma
grazie anche a coloro andiamo avanti
allora voglio vederti con questo sembra
qualcosa di strano ma in realtà è molto
più semplice di quello che immaginate è
un massaggio a favore per la faccio
eccolo
e bello oddio a un vero e proprio nemico
un pochino a spalmare perché super
liquido poco basta e sono scivolato a
far scivolare qui nelle the chiedersi se
la seconda della grandezza del viso e
andate a massaggiare dal basso verso
l'alto con un'azione antico cioè 90 con
un semplice passaggio principali reti 10
anni e liste rete la vostra faccia senza
piller promozione straordinaria brand
arcova adesso voglio provare anch'io
dico altro ancora come massa sul fa
senza donatella versace ma cui ce lo
specchio
penso che passerò le mie serate davanti
a netflix
con questo prossimamente su per
rilassarmi io non volevo passato s'è
addormentato vedrete quello per la testa
questo è meglio perché la testa è il
assante però non ha nessun beneficio
vero dice secondo me si può al proprio
tipo di uso della mattino così misera
sia con 18 anni andiamo avanti con
questa figliata sapete che quando si
parla di disney io sono in prima linea e
sono delle maschere appunto phone
non so se la faccia della principessa o
si no c'è tutta la principessa e delle
parole bene quale proviamo dai quando
dobbiamo provare le principesse per me
una provi tu sopra il trucco giusto per
farlo allora proviamo biancaneve che
quella che mi piace di meno e ce la
togliamo amori ma i gusti allora belle e
alla rosa buona jasmine al caviale d'oro
hulk
cosa vorrà dire celermente al collagene
a d'oro nel proprio del chirurgo ariel
per la nera e biancaneve proprio basic
alla mela e il nostro settore morì devo
piangere ma nel dubbio di una scarsa di
mela ma che non è che sembrano di
fragola amo immagine di sé meramente ed
è velenosa come la meraviglia che viaggi
con 5 tour è un peccato però usarle
perché non cessi visi beh allora qualità
ne ho viste di miglioristi esatto
diciamo che secondo me
comunque mi piace molto marina che in
metri col metodo scientifico lei si che
si mette una maschera con trucco sopra è
certo no diciamo che io non avevo visto
per la protezione
mi immaginavo che fossero però proprio
con la faccia della principessa così è
un po tipo découpage cioè un po dei
fiori un po di come la senti fresca
fresca fresca tra l'odore internamente
non luoghi ma sono ancora marina pensavo
di cantare lusignoli quando devi buttare
via le maschere se non sono
completamente asciutte un passo saluto
con la maschera ti passi anche sul collo
supe coltello ok qui perché comunque il
prodotto che rimaste nella macerie
ancora utile
lo so lo lascia lì dopo il video
andiamo avanti andiamo avanti per una
cosa non thailandese ma che qua non
avevo ancora trovato è di origins maschi
miser si chiama quindi è un ottimizzate
della pelle pre maschera un primer per
le maschere viso
in realtà buono e hanno il profumo è uno
spray fresco non le vogliono noi non
sono attualmente è visto che ai pre
maschera tocca me adesso secondo me
arrivato il momento non ve la faccio
vedere la m sorridi in camera
eccoli dovrebbe essere una foca prego
fammi allora è animal acqua mask allora
sempre di arcova questa cosa che non sa
già da un po in bocca quindi buona anche
alle nostre buono 1 fino al gusto una
cosa molto bella che ho trovato che
trovo di questa maschera che il cotone e
molto spesso a differenza di asti e
contro agosto tvt si appiccicano questo
cotone molto spesso questo senso qualità
tanto santa toccandola ovvero si si
applica facilmente non è un buon odore
però l'odore delle masche non è poco
fondamentale
io abito soprattutto questa alla bava di
lumaca
secondo me non avrà un buonissimo d'ore
però in thailandia non di moda di più
questa qui a in particolare acqua
glicerina e stato di camomilla e
secrezione pilomat entrata e sodio
ialuronato prova di lumaca fa benissimo
ragazza
la cosa dica che quindi da nerone ancora
trovato i pacchetti con così tante
maschere questo qua per esempio da
cinque sono modifiche dottor l'art
il fango lo so però gli la maggior parte
sono minimo 2 che infatti hanno trovato
le masse avendo una è già il giorno dopo
è finita quando l'ha detto quindi dovete
farlo anche qua in italia
io posso togliermi nazione la maschera
secondo me no perché qua arriva l'ultimo
prodotto che è che ve lo dico a fare
ragazzi la meraviglia la meraviglia
pazzesca come ma io sto veramente
facendo tutto il video così a questa
finissima mano destra mano sinistra
che cosa ma adesso ma la sinistra tuo
regalo
mano sinistra
adoro cioè io ho visto questa cosa è
subito pensato a lui anche se non ho
idea di quale sia perché ha detto piano
di ca del collo no no era finito perché
mi piacciono queste mascherine molto
stile liberato quindi sembrava un po
quello tommy scheda però è una maschera
che a quanto pare serve per certo come
loro ma per i punti neri può esser a
vedere un attimo a noli fring e li na è
arrivata anche una certa per me quindi
ma questa cosa molto messa prodotto per
la mascella lista e fa raggiungere
una grande elasticità e riporta mi porta
alla sua forma originale che senso
vediamo come dentro a due cene solo c'è
anche una cartolina con la testimonial
ragazza sia i ragazzi di cosa stiamo
parlando
molto bella di super black mask ma
prendi tu la metti qua è lei a questa
funzione che secondo me bitti militano
che si chiama e io l'ho presa invece
rosa cioè non me ne sono fregata di te
le caratteristiche queste per la voce lo
stato visto rosa ho preso rosa però
perché lei sorride e lui perché non
sorridono male fa i due domande dovremo
dietro ci farebbe fare montato un
facetime una bella foto delle storie
instagram
e poi ci continueremo a interrogare per
tutta la vita
su quali fossero le reali proprietà di
questa maschera re pubblicherò anche
tutte le maschere che ho comprato e che
non mi ha fatto vedere perché sono
tantissime io magari mi tolgo la
maschera anche se mi dispiace un pochino
vediamo l'effetto trucco è un po come ai
15 di agosto ha detto questo noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video e iscrivetevi
al calare per perdere i prossimi video
sulla skin kerr e non vi mandiamo un
bacione
e ricordate di seguirla su instagram
facebook ti tic toc seguitemi su
instagram che è molto restare amabile
iscrivetevi al canale ragazzi perché
devo arrivare a un milione
quindi aiutatemi un bacione e io
continuo a massaggiarlo ciao
[Musica]